and whether race start with whether a
new round of severe storms is hammering
the Gulf Coast right now affecting
millions of people Texas and Louisiana
seem to be the hardest hit with much of
the Houston area underwater overnight
countless cars were stranded by
floodwaters and some people had to be
rescued flash flood watches are up in
six states and the rain is expected to
last into the weekend Mireya Villarreal
is in Houston where some areas got more
than five inches of rain overnight
yikes that's the worst downpours there
since hurricane Harvey the rain came
down overnight in sheets with rumbling
thunder and cracks of lightning it
battered this gas station
the storms winds pushed trash cans
around the lot the rare indoor shower
here been a big part waters streamed in
through the dome of the Houston Astros
ballpark mid game dousing fans flags are
howling and they are soaking wet and
rapidly rising flood waters shut down
roads across the city trapping car after
car after car this weather event is a
very serious one and everyone needs to
take it very seriously
last night city officials warned people
to stay off the roads
but not everyone heeded the message but
I can't here
stay
houston police chief art acevedo shot
video as he and his team patrolled the
area for stranded vehicles firefighters
found one car upside down in floodwaters
and were able to save the driver trapped
inside
they also battled flames at this home
during the storm Houston Fire is
investigating the cause Rabbit lightning
strikes in the area are one possibility
all right Maria Vol in Houston thank you